After breakfast, the two boys and Fagin played a game.
Fagin walked around the room.
He pretended he was in the street.
The two boys tried to take things from his pockets.
If Fagin felt them doing it, he would shout.
They played this game for a while.
Fagin asked Oliver to try and take a wallet from his coat pocket.
Oliver copied what the Artful Dodger did.
He told Oliver to always do what the Artful Dodger told him to do,...
...and one day he would be a great man.
Oliver asked to go out with the boys, and one day, at last, Fagin agreed.
They walked along the streets, but the boys did not hurry.
Oliver was surprised when he saw Charley Bates...
...take apples and oranges from the shops along the way and put them into his pockets.
He seemed to have a lot of pockets.
Oliver didn't like it and was about to go back to Fagin...
...when the Artful Dodger suddenly stopped and put his finger in front of his mouth.
"Can you see that old man at the bookshop?" asked the Artful Dodger.
Oliver saw an elderly gentleman standing outside the bookshop.
"He'll do," said the Artful Dodger.
Charley Bates agreed and the two boys began to walk toward the man.
Oliver walked behind them.
He didn't know what to do.
Then he saw the Artful Dodger put his hand in the gentleman's pocket,...
...take out a handkerchief, and give it to Charley Bates.
The two boys ran around the corner as quickly as they could.
Suddenly, Oliver understood everything.